now our probability problems will get a
little bit more interesting so let's say
I have a bag full of coins so this is my
bag of coins
it's my maybe it's a bowl of coins so a
bunch of coins in there right I didn't
need to draw it but I did anyway and
let's say that I know that nine of these
coins nine of them are normal so what do
I mean by normal it's just you know
let's say they're quarters and they have
a heads and a tails and that there's a
50% chance of getting a heads or 50%
chance of a tails
if you flip any of those coins and then
one of the coins is a two-sided head
coin two-sided head so essentially no
matter what you flip it it's going to be
a heads right so I have this bag what I
want to do is I'm going to you know
blindfold myself take stick my hand in
the bag and pick a coin out and then I'm
going to flip that coin I don't know I'm
going to flip it five times and my
question to you is what is the
probability that I get all five to be
heads
so the probability probability that I
get five heads 5 out of 5 heads so
whenever you see something unfamiliar
it'll always work it's good to do you
know maybe we'll do a tree or we'll do a
hybrid of a probability tree or
something else but you say well at the
very beginning of this experiment
something happens I'm going to pick a
coin out of this bag and so you could
say that there is a well how many coins
are there there's ten coins and I have
an equal probability of picking any one
of the coins let's say I can't feel
whether it's heads or tails
so I'm not I'm doing it with gloves on
right so I can't feel out the two head
sided coin so you take take my word for
it there's an equal probability to take
any one of these ten coins right there's
nine normal one weird with only with two
heads on it right so what's the
probability that I get a normal coin so
the probability of a normal well that's
there are nine normal coins out of the
ten equally likely coins I could get so
the probability of a normal is
nine out of ten so there's a nine out of
ten chance that this is a normal coin
this is called that normal and then
what's the probability that I get a
let's call it a 2's two-sided coin I'll
call it 2s well that's just 1 out of 10
I'm either going to get this or that I'm
not going to take nothing out of the bag
I assume okay so this is 1/10 side
chance that I get a two-sided coin right
and then whichever coin I get I'm going
to flip it five times in a row and I'm
not going to do the tree here because
the dru you know tree you know you I'd
have thirty two nodes on each side but
given this given the normal what is now
the probability of getting five in a row
and the way I'm going to write that is
the probability of five heads or you
know I could have written 5 out of 5
heads or whatever and then this upward
line this means given given that I have
a normal coin so if I can assume that I
had a normal coin what are the
probability that my next 5 so I'll say
this is 5 out of 5 heads well we figure
that out each time there's a 1/2
probability and and I'm going to do it
five in a row so it's 1/2 to the fifth
which equals one over 32
so the probability that I get 5 out of 5
heads given a normal coin is 1 out of 32
fair enough well what's the probability
what's the probability of 5 out of 5
heads 5 out of 5 heads given the
two-sided coin and I'm just a just
random notation I'm coming with the
two-sided but this this upward and
downwards line this vertical line that
means given well that's I'm definitely
going to get ome I could accurate I
could flip this coin a million times and
all of them are going to be heads so the
probability here is 1 out of 1 right I'm
definitely going to get a heads here so
what is the possible what it what are
the probabilities of so all I asked
initially is what are the what is the
probability that I get 5 out of 5
heads well this is going to be equal to
and I will switch colors arbitrarily
here just to keep things interested this
is going to be equal to the probability
that you get 5 out of 5 heads given
let's call that a normal coin give it a
normal coin times the probability that
you had a normal coin times the
probability of let's say normal right
plus and I'm running a little bit of
space the probability that you get 5 out
of 5 heads given the two-sided coin
times the probability that you had the
two-sided coin hopefully that makes
sense and you can kind of think of it in
this way you know what is what is the
probability of getting to this outcome
it is the probability that you picked a
normal coin and then given the normal
coin there's a 1 in 32 chance that you
got there so it'd be 132 times the
chance you get the normal coin so 9 out
of 10 and what's the probability of
getting here what's the probability that
you you you had to and in general in a
tree you just have to multiply all of
the nodes to get to that point to figure
out what's the property of getting there
and I think you if you watch the first
few videos it makes sense why that
happens so what's the probability of
this well there's a one-tenth chance
that you picked the two-sided coin and
then of course then you're guaranteed to
get all heads so then this is this is 1
1 times 1/10 and all I did here and here
is the same thing that I wrote up here
let me switch colors so what is so what
is this the probability of 5 out of 5
heads given a normal coin times the
probability of a normal coin well that's
just this this is the probability of 5
out of 5 heads given the normal coin
times the probability of a normal coin
and this is equal to what 9 over 329
over 320 and then this the probability
of 5 out of 5 heads given the two-sided
coin times the probability the two-sided
coin well this is the probability of 5
out of 5 heads given the two-sided coin
you're guaranteed to get 5 out of 5
and the probability of getting a
two-sided coin is 1 out of 10 so 1 out
of 10 this is this so this is equal to
110 so my probability of you know just
putting my hand in the bag taking out a
random coin and then flipping it five
times and getting all five heads is
going to be equal to this Plus this so
it's nine over 320 plus one over ten but
let's make that as a 300 so it's 320
that's thirty-two over 320 so nine plus
32 is 40 1 over 320 so that's
interesting but I'll let me ask you even
a even a more interesting question and
and this is something that you know this
this is why I think what we've learned
so far is useful what let's let's say
that I do get five out of my minutes so
I know that I got 5 out of 5 heads so
let me let me clear this up a little bit
just because I think it's getting over
good so let's say that I do get 5 out of
5 heads what is the probability that I
picked the two-sided coin so what we're
asking is what is the probability that I
picked the two-sided coin given that I
got 5 out of 5 heads and I hope you
understand what this what what I'm what
I mean here before we said oh you know
like for example I hope you see the
different this and what is the
probability of getting 5 out of 5 heads
5 out of 5 heads given the two-sided
coin well this is you know if I know I
have a two-sided coin I know that the
probability is equal to 1 I know that
I'm guaranteed to get 5 heads but this
is a little bit more interesting if I
flip a coin five times in a row and I
get a bunch of heads I'll say well I
either got you know maybe really lucky
with a normal coin or I picked the
two-sided coin and I don't know which
one I happened so there's a probability
I have to and so and of course the more
times you get a heads just intuitively
if I got a hundred heads in a row I'll
say well I probably picked the two-sided
coin or if I you know without actually
just looking at the coin
assuming that that's not acceptable you
know if I got a million heads in a row
we'd be really really sure that we pick
the two-sided coin but we're not
completely sure there's some probability
that I picked the fair coin and it just
happened to get heads a million times in
a row so how do we think about this well
I'll do it analytically and I'll draw it
out and hopefully both of them will make
sense to you and I'll probably have to
do it in the next video I'll see you
soon